So if for example, Grant earns $27,000 total, what is the total amount he's
going to have to pay in taxes? First figure out how much of his income falls
within each of these tax brackets. Then, I have listed the tax rate for each of
those brackets over in this left-hand column. So to figure out how much he's
going to pay in taxes from each of those brackets. Just multiply the income
that falls within that bracket by the rate of that bracket. Once you have all
of the taxes from each of the brackets, add all of them up to come up with the
total amount of tax Grant's going to have to pay. I'll write in a dollar sign
for you right here, and you don't have to write them in any of these slots at
all. Just write the numbers.